these jerks in the control room are
demanding that I get to music Monday but
I I don't want to and I don't want to
cuz I took a peek I took a peek at what
song they picked for me today before I
tell it to the group I want to know who
picked this
song I'll
wait I did Mr Davies All I Want For
Christmas Mr Davies is for you to be
fired
for making me listen to most popular
song probably ever written even though
it's only played for one month a year
the artist is Mariah Carey and the song
that we will now analyze to Plum The
Depths is All I Want for
Christmas I
don't Christmas there is I need don't
care about the
presne the Christmas tree I don't need
to end my stocking be upon the
fireplace Santa Claus will make me
happy toy on Christmas day I just want
to go my own more than you could ever
known make My Wish
Come All I Want For Christmas Is
You
You released nearly 30 years ago it's
currently number one on Billboard's
greatest of alltime holiday songs and
has earned her an estimated $72 million
it's Timeless that was my goal was to do
something Timeless that didn't feel like
the '90s which is when I wrote it you
wrote very poignantly about the fact
that your childhood was messy that it
was far from perfect and that in many
ways what you want to give to your kids
and to your fans is this perfect magical
Christmas yeah that's
[Music]
true can I put a pause here it's a Bop
it's a great song and it's it's actually
acceptable to play now you know I'm a
big stickler on don't play Christmas
music during Advent this isn't a
Christmas song this is an advent song
it's an advent song because it is a song
in anticipation of Christmas she's not
saying I'm so glad what I got for
Christmas was you it's not it's all I
want for Christmas what I'm Desiring as
I look forward in this season toward
Christmas is you it's Advent so it
checks that box now it's a secular song
right yeah but look there plenty of
great secular Christmas songs not as
important as say silent night but
they're good songs not as good as a des
F
de
but you know pretty good and if it's
going to be secular think about the
great message here the great message is
I don't want material stuff I'm not even
going to stay up waiting for a sleigh
and reindeer on my rooftop I just want
you I want you presumably my husband so
that we can get married and have a
family which is the the domestic church
right it's a symbol of the family the
marriage is symbol of Christ's love for
his church compare this to a Santa
Baby the shap under the tree for me
that's just all materialism right now go
to jus.com
nsyt letter y letter T I have got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the Season we all know
the holiday season can be a little bit
hectic the shopping the cooking the long
list of things to do if you're not
because I've discovered a gift that is
both thoughtful and transformative the
gift of genus cell skincare from now
until Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com letter y
letter T treat yourself and your loved
ones to the absolute best skincare in
the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles fine line skin redness sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with jus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back their products use the best stuff
out there on the market the prices are
incredibly competitive and in fact they
will give you special holiday discounts
because they know even if they lose
money on this order they know that you
are going to keep coming back that is
how good it is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping
jus.com
nsyt today keep going
[Music]
Mariah
baby all the
[Music]
of
every every the children left feels
it and everyone is
s did you ever dream it was going to be
that
big I mean
really um I really didn't know and I I
tried not to think about it
but you know of course we always hope
that what you're doing you know people
are going to like what you're doing and
it's going to be successful and
everything but it is really um surpassed
what I thought it would
[Music]
[Applause]
do
baby
forr with
you baby
you could even
actually uh read through the music into
a higher more religious sense just as
you can with with a a fair bit of pop
music which is that our our longings or
longings of Love even erotic longings
can be not suppressed or denied but
actually turned up toward the proper
place uh in in God this is what the
Divine Comedy is about so even that only
one for Christmas is you that's all we
will we just want our Lord in the manger
and we can have an intuition of the
proper love for God in romantic love and
in the family and we look we get it we
get it with Mariah there's a reason why
it's the most popular song of the season
and that season of course is advent I
don't want a lot for Christmas there is
just one thing I need don't care about
the present underneath the Christmas
tree